je suis professeur de mathématiques une
matière qui n'a pas toujours bonne
écoute
sion et avec laquelle chacun son
histoire personnelle plus ou moins
heureuses ça fait 13 ans que je suis
dans le même collège
un collège en zone sensible réseau
d'éducation prioritaire plus à la
rentrée assez rapidement devant mes
élèves en difficulté je me suis retrouvé
professeur en difficulté j'avais beau
avoir ma maîtrise de mathématiques je me
suis bien souvent retrouvé débordé des
mini en difficulté à gérer un groupe
class est enseigné les mathématiques
j'ai souvent hésité à arrêter
je me suis inscrite à toutes les
formations qui arrivait sur les élèves
en difficulté et en formation continue
j'ai découvert les kits active alors la
formation continue sérieusement ou vous
soyez vous faut pas s'en priver c'est
acquérir des techniques de méthodes de
survie en environnement hostile
tu sait jamais sur quoi tu vas tomber
mais au moins tu es armés j'ai ensuite
eu la chance de devenir maman
deux fois et tout le monde sait que
c'est lorsqu'on devient maman qu'on
cesse de croire définitivement s'il est
facile d'éduquer dans la crèche bio
écolo bienveillante de mes enfants j'ai
découvert des ateliers d'habileté
parental alors on dit qu'il ya pas de
manuels pour être parents il ya quand
même des ouvrages qui est vraiment je
suis donc assez logiquement aller me
former à paris au grand atelier des
parents pour pouvoir partager ces outils
car les idées qu ils en valent la peine
mérite d'être répondu autant ces outils
ont enrichi personnellement et
professionnellement autant immobilier en
mauvaise posture
je me suis retrouvé bien souvent en
difficulté et même bien plus souvent en
colère face à des pratiques éducatif que
je sais
être néfaste pour l'acquisition de
connaissances pour l'estimé de soi pour
le développement de l'autonomie la
motivation la créativité
pendant treize ans fait donc mis en
place des outils que j'ai testée et
prouvée qui ont évolué depuis qu'ils
seront toujours amené à évoluer mais qui
ont été vraiment utile car ils ont
permis de sortir de cette colère moi qui
me voulait moi qui me disait
bienveillante la bienveillance cet état
d'esprit cette posture qui consiste à
veiller à ce que tout le monde aille
bien alors je vais essayer de vous
présenter ces cinq outils sur laquelle
ça crie mais pratique dans ma classe et
dans mon établissement le premier outil
et la connaissance de soi
indissociable de l'estimé de soi et la
confiance en soi
alors pour accéder à tout ça il faut
réussir à prendre certaines distances je
vous parlais de l'exemple de l'enfant
qui traverse la rue sont regardés qui
manque de se faire écraser
il n'est pas rare de voir la panique du
parent se transformer quasi
instantanément en colère et kas qui se
met à lui hurler dessus alors que
l'enfant lui-même encore paniquer
lorsqu'on est soumis au stress
lorsqu'on est pris par le rythme qu'on
ne prend pas le temps de se poser alors
on a tendance à confondre les émotions à
mélanger les causes et les conséquences
ne peut pas toujours être ni très
logique ni très cohérent il est pourtant
important de savoir connaître et
reconnaître ses émotions
ce permis aux élèves de connaître les
différents profils d'apprentissage de
savoir reconnaître le sien est ce que
j'ai plutôt une mémoire visuelle est ce
que je retiens mieux ce que j'entends ou
à ce que j'ai besoin de bouger pour
pouvoir faire le point il est important
d'être
dans un climat de confiance la
bienveillance instaure cette confiance
lorsqu'on est capable de lui accorder le
bénéfice du doute qu'on peut réellement
pensé ce n'est pas par laxisme ou
mauvaise volonté qu'un enfant ne rentre
pas dans les apprentissages
alors on peut vraiment se mettre à
travailler sur quels sont mes points
faibles et quelles sont mes points forts
ces temps de respiration où l'on se pose
pour pouvoir faire un petit peu vite je
me suis pas posé presqu'île où l'on se
pose pour pouvoir définir ce qui est la
base
donc soit est alors pouvoir s'ouvrir à
la connaissance du monde
un des objectifs du collège est de faire
acquérir à tous les élèves un certain 5
de connaissance l'un des gros reproches
que les élèves sont le collège fait de
s'ennuyer
si pour rené clément nous avons besoin
d'y être confronté
d'où l'importance des manipulations
sciences expérimentales des sorties
culturelles des voyages linguistiques
il y a un outil qui ne contredit pas
tout ça est au contraire j'enrichis
c'est internet
si on m'invite les parents les
enseignants à parler d'internet il y en
aurait des choses il y aurait des choses
entendre et surtout une certaine panique
pourtant ce serait précisément
déconnectez-vous voire obsolète de ne
pas reconnaître que google et leurs amis
qu'ils se réfèrent et trouve toutes
sortes super tutoriel sur internet
et justement parce qu'ils peuvent
trouver de tout il est important
notre rôle d'éducateur est important
pour pouvoir leur permettre de
comprendre l'outil est d'être protégés
dans leur utilisation
notre génération d'élèves la générale
z celle qui a grandi avec internet on ne
peut pas leur imposer de faire comme si
ça n'existait pas en mathématiques
salut 10 ans de se rendre compte que
assis dans la classe on pouvait calcul
est assez précisément la distance entre
la porte de leur maison et le portail du
collège ou plutôt parce que c'est ce qui
les intéressait à ce moment là la
distance entre la salle de classe et la
porte de la cantine internet
et comme le monde en perpétuel
changement il faut faire une analyse
critique savoir s'adapter et rebondir
face à de nouvelles situations
dans cette logique un parcours
professionnel fait de différents métiers
successifs ou même simultanée est
envisageable
les parcours atypique du monde entier
montrant les différents chemins
impossible devenus possibles sont aussi
très inspirant on parlait tout à l'heure
de respiration internet est une de leurs
sources d'inspiration
le troisième enseignement prend
davantage de sang en établissement
sensible où on déplore souvent une
dégradation du climat scolaire une
augmentation des incivilités les
agressions de la violence souvent les
conflits viennent une incompréhension
d'un jugement trop hâtif d'un regard un
peu trop centré sur soi faciliter
l'ouverture ayant des ménages est ce que
j'enseigne à mes élèves dans la classe
et en ateliers d'expression depuis
quelques années pour cela je les ai
outils d'outils de communication non
violente
alors quand on parle d'éducation non
violente méconnaissance ou jugements
hâtifs on a tendance à penser
et au laxisme alors je vais essayer
d'éclaircir un petit peu tout ça avec un
outil que je pratique avec mes élèves et
qui inspirait des graines des médiateurs
de l'université de la paix si les bleus
arrivent assez rapidement sur la
distinction entre la tortue qui ne
cherche pas de solution et qui se
renferme avec le lion qui a sa solution
et qu'il impose qui fera qui menace qui
fait du chantage qui rapporte à la
maîtresse ils ont tendance à croire que
je leur demande d'être caméléon de
privilégier la relation et l'autre à
tout prix quitte à s'effacer
évidemment il ne s'agit pas de ça mais
de par les dauphins s'être être
intelligent capable de communiquer comme
nous je crois qu'ils parlent en message
qui décrit ce qui se passe à partir de
ce qu'ils voient l'effet ses émotions
lorsque on distingue bien les problèmes
des personnes
alors chacun est disposé à chercher des
solutions qui conviennent à tout le
monde et c'est aussi en les enjeux du
collège l'acquérir
ce socle de compétences qui fera qu'on
sera capable de vivre en société
d'ailleurs quand on demande aux élèves à
quoi leur sert l'école après le très
convenue bas à prendre pour avoir un
métier vient le trait réaliste et très
spontanée la voir mes copains je laisse
john lennon me faire la transition
il parle de bonheur dans la vie et à
l'école une grosse problématique de
notre société
l'éducation nationale en particulier
c'est le poids les sentiments négatifs
de tous les différents acteurs
les élèves se sentent stressés face aux
évaluations inquiet façon réactions
éventuelles
d'un enseignant de leurs parents -
sentiment d'incompétence ne sont pas
intéressés je rencontre des parents qui
sont inquiets triste et très en colère
de ne pas savoir comment aider leurs
enfants en difficulté
quant à mes collègues en fait le caire
je préfère même pas parler la salle des
professeurs qui est loin d'être le lieu
le plus ressources d'un établissement
ma solution à moi n'était que pour faire
face à cette colère parce que chez moi
c'est ce qui a tendance à l'emporter la
peur et la tristesse se transformer vite
en colère chez les transformer c'est de
créer justement cette bulle de joie à la
fois protectrice et moteur d'énergie
chaque être humain un besoin vital de
créer à partir de ce qu'il est le maître
d'un rôle passif d'exécutants c'est un
peu tué ce qui a de vivant en lui les
élèves ne sont pas des bocaux à remplir
mais des potentiels a révélé la culture
de l'encouragement ça ça prend ça
s'enseigne dans une période difficile
après pas si lointaine où j'ai vraiment
je me suis vraiment questionné sur une
éventuelle reconversion professionnelle
en fait je crois que si j'avais pas mes
enfants je pense que ça aurait été une
expatriation humanitaire j'ai eu besoin
d'encouragements pour rester mon
conjoint m'a fait la remarque marquantes
qui n'a pas droit de t'arrêter shahrivar
en une matière horrible et traumatisante
je vous parlais tout à l'heure des
histoires personnelles de chacun avec
les mathématiques
donc tu matière horrible et
traumatisante
j'arrive à la rendre agréable
il ya eu ça il y aussi les mots de mes
élèves
parce que je leur apprends à donner des
signes de reconnaissance posthume comme
moi en avons besoin
c'est un moment important de chaque fin
d'année ou sur une feuille blanche
pendant une heure nous écrivons les
choses positif un souvenir marquant
et c'est un véritable bonheur de les
recevoir et de retrouver des élèves
quelques années après kiss ressort de
son portefeuille
un vieux papiers tout froissé ou qui
raconte qu'il est toujours dans sa table
de chevet ou affiché dans sa chambre car
c'est mon parti pris les travailler sur
le bonheur contre la violence scolaire
le travail et sur la cohésion sociale
parce que c'est un des enjeux devenir
heureux au collège est dir est dit être
heureux et cela aussi bien pour les
élèves que pour les enseignants alors
cultiver le bonheur et le partage et
picasso disait que le sens de la vie et
de trouver ces dons et que le but de la
vie et d'en faire don aux autres c'est
ce que j'essaye de faire en particulier
cette année d'un nouvel atelier
d'engagement citoyen baptisé colibri
chaque élève qui le souhaitent est
invitée à faire sa part et à s'engager
dans l'organisation l'événement festif
et fédérateur pour tout l'établissement
ainsi on a pu organiser la journée
mondiale de la foncière où chacun est
valorisée individuellement dans une
action collective
ils se sont capables libre de créer de
proposer a le sentiment fort
d'appartenir une communauté et de
contribuer à son bien-être
ce sont les actions dans l'établissement
nous avons aussi eu la chance de pouvoir
grâce à des associations locales
solidaire de partir participer au noël
pour les sdf de saint joseph nous avons
pu leur servir des repas
les élèves ont été libres de décider de
ce qu'il faisait et c'est un des
souvenirs les plus marquants que nous
avons en commun
nous avons aussi pu organiser un
carnaval pour le mardi gras de cette
année pour les enfants malades de
l'hôpital qui ne pouvaient alors pas
sortir heureusement je ne suis pas tout
seul dans mon établissement
nous avons il y a d'autres faits les
comme moi et ce qui est fait les laisse
passer la lumière dans mon collège on
jardine bio on lombricompost les déchets
de la cantine
rien que pour ça mes collègues j'ai des
frissons en fait on lombricompost les
déchets de la cantine ont chance le
maloya
on traverse l'île sur les traces du
grand raid
on danse pour la gentillesse on se fait
des fruits ans dans cette logique de
partage me suis engagé depuis quelques
années d'un groupe académique de
formateurs l'idée de à partir d'apports
théoriques de connaissances sur la
pédagogie positive la communication
bienveillante la connaissance des
différentes méthodes d'apprentissage de
psychologie de l'enfant de permettre à
chacun de faire ce temps de respiration
de s'inspirer de ce qui existe et de
pouvoir construire ce qui correspond
réellement à son établissement et à sa
classe nous intervenons dans les
établissements et l' avantage c'est que
en étant nous mêmes en poste ce sur quoi
nous allons échanger et concrètement
relier avec ce que nous vivons dans nos
classes et en retour je m'enrichis
vraiment des échanges de pratiques avec
ses collègues
l'idée de l'accepter un instant de
sortir de sa zone de confort pour
laisser la magie s'opérer et voir que la
bienveillance rend les choses
confortable pour tous que ce soit les
élèves et les éducateurs professeurs
parents qui voient partir du moment où
nous sommes en relation avec d'autres
personnes que nous soyons patron
collègues amis pour moi alors toutes les
choses se sont mis à leur place et j'ai
trouvé ma pièce en mettant en ne
connaissant mieux en mettant nettoyer de
colère j'en avais vraiment besoin en
étant connecté au monde et par internet
en relation authentique et joyeuse avec
deux personnes engagées comme aux as
mais je vais pouvoir enfin que je suis
déjà je contribue à ce mouvement mondial
pour la gentillesse et la bienveillance
dans une école bienveillante dans un
monde bienveillant expert en
communication non violent
on aurait alors des boîtes à outils pour
rester dans l'image de la boîte à outils
l'idée n'est pas de présenter les outils
et le jour même de la présentation
espérer que tous sachent comment les
utiliser et tout le monde en même temps
mais de savoir ce qui existe et qui
quand comment les utiliser lorsqu'on se
sent prêt qu'on en a besoin en vie et
que si rien ne nous conviant savait que
ses propres outils
dans cette école non seulement
bienveillant on apprendrait que faire sa
part n'est jamais inutile une seule
goutte d'eau peut faire déborder un vase
un seul vannerie pencher la balance et
qu'une graine peut être en sommeil des
années et ne se remettra jamais que
quand toutes les conditions s'y prêtent
c'est ce que je vous invite à faire
aller semer en faisant grandir les
enfants dont la gentillesse la
bienveillance
ils pourront à leur tour allait semer la
wiz iront le monde des affaires le monde
politique le monde associatif le monde
de l'éducation
quant à tous ceux qui ne croient pas
l'impossible je suis non pas désolé mais
heureuse de vous dire que c'est déjà en
cours